[Music]
hello and good morning from downing
street where the new prime minister is
preparing to chair her first cabinet
meeting after a sweeping reshuffle last
night now around the top table are many
of her key supporters with senior roles
going to loyalists and allies and which
is soon as backers striking by their
absence now the new look government is
expected to discuss a multi-billion
pound plan to try and help households
and businesses struggling with soaring
energy costs with an announcement on any
emergency measures due as soon as
tomorrow now it's an issue likely to
feature heavily in pmq's this lunch time
when mistrust will go head-to-head
against sakirshama for the first time
well our first report this morning comes
from our chief political correspondent
john craig
frankly the idea of being stuck in a
lift with kier stalin strikes me is
extremely boring liz truss's
uncharitable verdict on the labour
leader during tory leadership hustings
today less than 24 hours after walking
into 10 downing street she'll clash with
sakir at prime minister's questions for
the first time
in her commons debut as prime minister
before then after completing her cabinet
appointments last night miss truss will
hold the first meeting of her new
cabinet in downing street
in a call of rishi sunac supporters and
promotion for allies quasi-cuateng is
confirmed as chancellor zweller bravaman
home secretary and james cleverley
foreign secretary
but the big winner is mastroz's close
friend therese coffey
who becomes deputy prime minister along
with health secretary
for the new pm her priorities are the
economy energy and the nhs
as strong as the storm may be
i know that the british people are
stronger i am confident that together we
can ride out the storm
we can rebuild our economy
and we can become the modern brilliant
britain that i know we can be
there'll be action on energy bills this
week
nobody fails to realize the size of the
problem it is an extraordinary problem
any mp now knows what problems
businesses are facing and individuals
have similarly been facing those
problems
that's likely to be the focus of the
labour leaders attack at pmqs
but sakir warned his mps this week not
to underestimate mistrust
saying she's a talented politician who's
got to the top through hard work and
determination
in clashes with saquia starmer at prime
minister's questions over the past two
years boris johnson called the labour
leader captain hindsight a chlorinated
chicken
a pointless human bollard and captain
crasher rooney snooze fest
given that liz truss has already called
sakir extremely boring she's likely to
aim a few more insults at him
but back in downing street as well as
facing political challenges as trus and
her husband are beginning a new life
john craig sky news
[Applause]
now mr truss's new look cabinet will
meet for the first time this morning so
let's uh take a closer look in some more
detail at who is who now as expected
quasi quatering the former business
secretary has been confirmed as a new
chancellor of the exchequer james
cleverley is the new foreign secretary
sweller bravoman who also stood as a
candidate for leadership is going to be
the new home secretary ben wallace has
been named as defence secretary so he
stays on and therese coffey has been
appointed as the new deputy prime
minister and secretary of state for
health jacob rees-mogg is the new york
business secretary and brandon lewis has
been named justice secretary now nadim
sahawi who served just two months as
chancellor is now a cabinet office
minister
well in some of the other appointments
wendy morton has been named as chief
whip a key role penny mordant who was
another leadership hopeful is now leader
of the house of commons and kemi badanok
is also in cabinet she's been appointed
international trade secretary
well kit malt house is the new education
secretary
all right let's bring in our political
correspondent tomorrow cohen who is here
with us throughout the morning tomorrow
good morning to you so we've laid out
who's in and who's out just take us
through some of those appointments well
look it was a bit of a bloodbath
politically speaking yesterday new prime
minister liz trust comes in
pays full some tribute to boris johnson
here on the steps of downing street but
even before she got in the door many
number 10 staff and aides have been told
their services were no longer required
and when she appointed her cabinet many
of which were not particularly
surprising we'd heard for some time that
we'd see quasi-cuateng as chancellor for
example uh james cleverley to the
foreign office and some of these new
cabinet ministers had already been
holding talks with their new departments
in preparation for it jacob rees-mogg at
the business department that appointment
will surprise a few people but i think
the first takeaway from this is it's a
complete purge of wishy sunax supporters
those who had thought that liz trust
particularly in the light of not having
that resounding a win with the members
might try to reach out were left
disappointed and a bit dismayed now you
may see rishi sunak supporters get into
some of the more junior ranks who will
be appointed today so it may not they
may not be completely cast out but
certainly we're seeing liz trust
appointing her close supporters and her
close allies during this campaign and
for those who said that boris johnson
had not appointed all the talents to his
cabinet had been more concerned about
rewarding his friends than getting the
best people in the jobs i don't think
we'll see those concerns quiet and down
but i think another thing that's really
really noteworthy is in the top jobs liz
truss quasiquating james cleverley and
suella bravaman leadership contender as
well at the home office there is there
are no white men and that is such an
important moment for diversity in
british politics and particularly for
the conservative party it's a really
remarkable moment and one that should be
should be noted um and the decisions
that she has made to not have people
from the ritty soon ex from other parts
of the party goes against all the advice
that it was sort of put around in the
final moments or the leadership contest
i mean what does it tell us about her
early decision making do we think well
some of you see next supporters were
warning her you have to reach out across
the party not just to rishi sunax
supporters but also to make sure that
you have the balance within the party of
the right-wing brexiteers the likes of
suella braveman and jacob rees-mogg but
also those more on the liberal what you
call the one nation wing of the
conservative party to balance that out
and although you could say that therese
coffee who's her key ally and we'll be
speaking to this morning is on that wing
of the party
there are some concerns that she's gone
too much for for the right wingers the
key challenge now for liz trust is
tomorrow she will unveil her support
package for energy bills if that goes
down well that will quieten a lot of the
discontent down especially if she puts
some risky scenic supporters in the
ministerial ranks that will quieten them
down the risk is that having appointed a
cabinet full of those close to her who
agree with her
if that doesn't pan out well the
discontent could start coming pretty
quickly from those who feel alienated
feel disgruntled that they have been
sort of cast out of her administration
we'll come on some other appointments in
a moment let's focus on the appointment
of who's going to be in number 11. and
that relationship between prime minister
and chancellor is essential if you can
have a a well-run government i mean talk
to us about the relationship between liz
trust and quasi-cuato so liz tross is
somebody who's she's been in cabinet for
eight years she's not someone who has
tons of close friends in politics but
the ones she does have are therese
coffee who is now deputy prime minister
and quasi-quatern who is now at number
11. he's been business secretary for a
number of years he's very immersed in
the whole issue of energy bills and he
has you know a phd in economic history
from cambridge he's well regarded and he
is one of the few survivors from boris
johnson's cabinet and it's no surprise
that he's in there he's already written
an article in the financial times
earlier this week about the need for
what you call fiscal loosening spending
money on energy bills he'll be meeting
bank chiefs this morning to talk more
about that because we expect at the
first cabinet meeting which will be held
at 8 30 this morning
the cabinet will be told some of the
details of the energy bill package they
will need to effectively approve it and
she will be no doubt be asked questions
about it by kierstarma at this lunch
time her first appearance of course she
won't set out the details because that's
coming tomorrow but she'll give some
strong signals about it and
that will be an interesting one pmq's
because liz trust has said during the
campaign i'm not the best performer i'm
not the slickest we saw her speech here
last night there was a clear contrast to
boris johnson wasn't there they didn't
have no jokes no no jokes it was quite
serious it was quite business-like and
in the commons you do and she's
obviously she's been a cabinet minister
a long time she doesn't know how to
perform in the comments but you know you
need to sort of get the benches behind
you going a bit and we'll see if she
takes a slightly different tone from the
sort of quite straight down the line
list trust that we've seen so far we'll
talk about that in a moment but just
just sticking with that plan to help you
with their energy bills um we have some
reporting on what we might be seeing
better talking yesterday about it being
a huge shock and all planned a huge
amount of money being spelt have we got
any more detail from the source we're
speaking to about what there may be in
it so what we understand is that having
railed against the idea of giving people
what liz trust called handouts i.e money
to help pay their energy bills
we are now
we now know that she is looking at a
freeze of energy bills as proposed by
the labour party she said that it was
not something she
wanted to go down many of her supporters
have talked about doing something more
targeted we know she's looking at a
freeze of energy bills at the level of
around two and a half thousand pounds
now to give you a sense of this has not
been confirmed yet to give you a sense
of what that is so the current price cap
is just under two thousand pounds
under the previous government boris
johnson and british cenac people given
400 pounds each to help with their
energy bills so that is so it's
basically it's around the current level
of energy bills
and they're looking at a freeze at that
level and also support for businesses
who are struggling as well if she does
that that is really as paul johnson put
yesterday said yesterday of the ifs a
big bazooka it's massively expensive
it's probably over 100 billion pounds
but you could certainly say she would
have seen the scale of the challenge and
risen to it so it looks like her and her
team are preparing something very very
significant the key questions um
which we were discussing yesterday are
how exactly it's paid for this talk of a
mechanism whereby they freeze the
wholesale price of gas and the
government loans money to the energy
companies the question is is that all
gonna be funded by borrowing she
obviously doesn't want a windfall tax
will she you turn on the idea of a
winful tax or is there gonna be a
suggestion that we will pay it back on
our bills years into the future which
you can imagine could be quite
politically difficult so a lot of
questions to answer and frankly getting
it out the door this quickly perhaps
does mean
that of course she's under pressure to
do so it does mean there's going to be a
focus on how the details really been
worked out yeah is there a sense as to
which one they're leaning towards it it
would feel to me from some of the
reporting i'd be reading that borrowing
the money is the the most is the
quickest and most effective way of doing
it at this point and then paying it back
over decades yes the question is of
course will people be told that they
will be paying it back over decades in
contrast to labor saying well we'd get
the energy companies to pay for it so i
think how exactly it's funded and
whether she
goes against what she said during the
campaign which is that she won't extend
the current windfall tax be surprised if
she does do that but that is going to be
one of the key questions and exactly how
the mechanism will work with the energy
companies and what that will mean for
britain's sort of reputation on
international markets all these things
are going to be picked over tomorrow but
i think today will be more about
signaling about
saying what sort of package she's
thinking about because she'll get
questions on this at prime minister's
questions and whether she's seen as
having a win over kierstan or whether
she's got any good lines in her back
pocket written for her by her team in
order to cut we've seen during this
campaign she's been very political
hasn't she she's been very undiplomatic
about nicolas sturgeon about mark
drakeford in wales calling him a low
energy jeremy corbyn what names might
she have ready to say to kierstama
because this is the first pm queues is
when prime ministers often try and sort
of rally the benches behind them with a
few kind of uh more pointed remarks
about the opposition ventures we'll see
what she's got seems she's funniest when
she's off the cuff when she has those
prepared involves like that carl alter
kiev line it didn't really land very
well so it will be interesting to see
whether the prepared remarks that
they're probably going through around
about now are going to be going to be
funny enough let's uh have a little go
through the newspapers this morning
tomorrow and of course uh i mean all of
them dominated by um liz trust and her
speech yesterday yeah this is the front
page of the front page of the telegraph
we've got which is uh
we can write outstanding that's of
course what she said um she missed the
storm herself she turned up to speak
only just well-timed just just in
between downpours yesterday i mean talk
to us about some of the details they've
got there they've also got that line
about the energy bills being frozen at
two and a half grand they do which are
sky news understands um as well um it
talks at all the papers focus on um what
she said about energy and also one about
her about her cabinet and the fact that
very few students supporters have
survived
we also
know that during that cab during those
cabinet appointments it took quite a few
hours because obviously she called
president zalensky in ukraine her first
call as promised and also spoke to joe
biden at the u.s president yesterday as
well so that's why but but by recent
standards it was pretty quick in terms
of a reshuffle because we knew a lot of
the people in advance so in the light of
winning
a more a slimmer victory than we had
expected she didn't appear to really
change her her thinking there's also
been quite a bit of comment in the
papers about some of the other
leadership contenders particularly kemi
baden-ock obviously one of the stars of
the leadership contest not getting one
of the jobs we expected her to more of a
front-facing job like education
secretary and instead being given more
of a backroom role in international
trade well one that keeps her away as
well indeed i wonder if that was a part
of the thinking possibly
because the mirror
the conservatives obviously saying
you now fix the britain you lot broke
and of course reminding us that the
conservatives have been in government
for some time are they
sort of um giving her any chance at all
to try and get through it what are they
calling for there
they're saying she has to deliver now
that there's you can't no no more no
more complaining because you know um
that they're saying that uh it's it's 12
years of conservative government which
has got us into this mess that's the
daily mirror's view and there's also a
lot of uh chat about boris johnson's
speech yesterday which of course we
witnessed about how um it's a bit bitter
and gave us a bit of a hint that he may
not be departing the political scene i'm
not going to talk about cincinnatus
again because it gave me a bit of a
headache trying to work out exactly what
he was trying to say let's look at the
daily mail which uh of course supports
this trust and wants to get the best
possible start together we can ride out
the storm and attacking the left-wing
twitter arty uh for not for not liking
but not for not liking liz for us a
little look at that and a picture of
this trust walking in it was quite it
was quite a daunting walk from that car
to the to the podium and he shouted
pretty well indeed especially when
you've just had an unexpected um
flight back to and from scotland uh in
the morning we've got the eye here as
well um they are talking about the trust
era begin beginning with a tax warning
and she did talk in that speech on the
steps of downing street about about uh
tax cuts i mean this is going to be the
big thing isn't it because she's going
to cut taxes but then borrow and then
pay i mean
and we'll talk to his coffee about this
sorting out the nhs making sure people
can get a gpa appointment get getting
britain working again you know with lots
of discussion about how people can't get
gp appointment delays put in a passport
office delays everywhere and she says
she's going to sort all of that out well
that all costs money and if you're
spending 100 billion pounds on energy
bills there may not be very much money
left over for all these things
especially since she also wants to
increase defense spending quite
significantly by the end of the decade
we'll speak to teresa about exactly that
because as health secretary of course um
liz trust has said that she's going to
get rid of that social health and social
care levy she is they're still going to
borrow the money and she said they'll
still tackle the backlogs with the same
amount of money we just won't be paying
it um on our national insurance and
she's also talked about how she wants
more of the money to go into social care
because she says that it's you know
there's problems in the social care
system which are making things more
difficult for the nhs which i'm sure the
social care
sector would be cheering but in the nhs
they'll be saying there are six million
people on the waiting list and we
desperately need that money so these are
the difficult decisions that that she
will have to make as prime minister and
of course they'll be discussing it now
as they prepare for the first cabinet
let's look ahead a little bit if we can
to prime minister's questions it's
always the highlight of the week for
people who are obsessed about these
things like you and i um i mean she has
said as you point out that she's not the
best of performers um
but how will she be preparing do you
think for for this moment look she knows
that she's gonna be tackled about energy
bills and she can't give all the answers
today because we're not expecting
details of that package until tomorrow
she's managed to be studiously vague
about this energy bill package for the
entirety of the leadership contest um i
wonder if kierstama will also go on
other subjects perhaps about the nhs
perhaps he may have some things from her
record to sort of dig up and and and
throw at the new prime minister i wonder
if she will mention being the third
female prime minister you know i
remember when theresa may did her first
pmqs she said you know
what the conservative party keep doing
with with women mps is making us prime
minister and i remember that being quite
a quite a big uh and that's definitely
the benches behind her yeah absolutely
and you know she she met she may well
mention mentioned at that point as well
um i wonder if kistan will mention the
margaret thatcher comparisons people
have made of her instagram pictures you
know um he may well have three good
lines to throw at her and i think how
how well she deals with them you know of
course being agile at prime minister's
questions is not the only important
thing but it's very important for
getting your party behind you yeah it is
but i do wonder if she's going to try
and govern in a different style to boris
johnson perhaps not being that sort of
buhari across the dispatch box is
actually what she's trying to go for
maybe she'll try and be a bit boring
because she wants to try and show
herself to be more serious look
uh
liz trust his ally say she's a serious
person for serious times and that she is
a hard worker she's a grafter she's got
to where she is through sheer
determination and wanting to change
things but she's also
during this campaign she's grown in
terms of her presentation and she seemed
to be really enjoying herself towards
the end of some of those hustings but
she was delivering lines that she had
delivered many times before and now
she's going to be having different
challenges thrown at her every day and
she is someone who sometimes speaks off
the cuff says things that you thought
you think did she mean to say that so i
think we'll we'll see liz trust the
leader today and
for many members of the public she's not
been in a lot of hugely public-facing
jobs she's not been health secretary or
education secretary most of her cabinet
roles have been perhaps more in the
shadows only coming forward at certain
times and so it'll be interesting to see
her front and center and exactly how she
how she comes across and how she handles
it they are preparing of course for well
first of all the first cabinet meeting
which should be taking place at around 8
30 is that right and then at 12 30 of
course prime minister's question sorry
12 o'clock let's um we're going to speak
now i think to the new deputy prime
minister and secretary of state for
health and social care that is to raise
coffee teres coffee good morning to you
thank you very much for being with us on
what's going to be a very busy day for
you and the government um first of all
let's just let's just talk about the
fact that liz trust has now been
appointed as prime minister um
what kind of vision do you think that
she'll be able to bring to the country
well the prime minister set out a very
clear vision yesterday on the doorsteps
of downing street uh focusing on the
economy in terms of growing the economy
in terms of tackling energy both
what we will do to help households and
businesses but the longer term of energy
supply and indeed the nhs and that's why
i've been honored to be uh
appointed as secretary of state for
health and social care
and i'm looking forward to working on
what i'm calling my abcd ambulances
backlogs care doctors and dentists
because ultimately this is about
patients getting the treatment and the
appointments they need to make sure that
they continue to get better
now i'm not going to ask you endlessly
about the huge package of help and
support for households and businesses
that is coming
only to to ask you is it coming and will
it be around about the range that we
have been reported about 100 130 billion
pounds
well clearly we've just been through a
significant leadership campaign but i
know liz uh being the serious person
that she is and recognising that we need
to hit the ground running we have been
working on plans as uh potential uh what
we could do uh recognizing that uh less
than 24 hours
we've still certainly working to make
sure we finalize the details of plans on
each of the points that we've set out
and i know that this week as the prime
minister
said yesterday there will be a further
announcement uh and i'm sure that that
will assure people uh indeed when they
hear what is going to be offered
i certainly will reassure people they've
been waiting quite a while to hear
something and and you contradict
yourself a little bit with them and miss
coffee said 24 hours then you said this
week so is it thursday or friday we're
going to finally hear the plan
well the prime minister's been in place
for less than uh 24 hours is what i was
referring to uh and indeed this uh
government uh
being appointed um not only the cabinet
last night as i'll be heading to downing
street a bit later but indeed the new
government this week yes the intention
is that there will be uh proposals set
out uh to parliament in the country uh
this week on what we are going to do
about energy
and the big question of course then will
be
something is going to be done it's going
to be a large amount of money spent and
how is that going to be paid for
because this trust of course wants to
cut taxes
well what we want to do is to grow the
economy and at the moment we have a high
tax burden uh we are making sure that we
want to focus on that by mixture of both
uh kind of encouraging investment rather
than putting up corporation tax uh but
also
making sure that we on our manifesto
commitment to the people that voted for
our party in 2019 and that's why we'll
be reversing the national insurance levy
but indeed we just need to continue to
focus on the supply side reform so
making it easier to do business making
it easier to run government in order to
make sure that the main focus is on the
outcomes that we deliver for people in
this country and to make sure we do that
as effectively and efficiently as
possible
i mean how challenging is it going to be
for you going into that brief of
health and social care to have that levy
being reversed that was going to be a
lot of money that those services in the
nhs and social care were really waiting
for
well the intention is that will be
funded from general taxation
and that is the case so we will continue
to invest the same amount
into health and social care that we
would setting out through the levy but i
think it's important that we
make sure we now get into the detail of
how we are going to make improvements
for patients to access
ambulances or their doctors or dentists
indeed many other aspects of primary
care that's needed in order to say keep
people um
healthy
so general taxation to pay for health
and social care but of course is it
going to be general taxation is going to
pay for this
package of measures to help households
with their energy bills or is that going
to be borrowing
well we'll be going through that i mean
ultimately uh
we receive money through taxation from
from from people and businesses and then
redistribute that accordingly to the
priorities set out in our manifesto and
the needs of the country so uh more will
be said about that uh aspects of that uh
in during this week
i mean you're suggesting that you could
fund this through taxation that's not
the case the wizard because this trust
is not going to fund this huge amount of
money that's going to be spent through
taxation and it wouldn't get anywhere
near the amounts that are needed
well this is how the government receives
money from
from people and businesses is through
general taxation and a variety of ways
but it's important that we continue to
focus on honoring our manifesto in 2019
that's what the prime minister also said
on the doorstep of downing street and
that's what we intend to do
i'm conscious that we
have a lot to still achieve but we
should recognize that
for example in the nhs that there's more
people working in the nhs than ever
before but also recognize that there are
still vacancies too so we need to
continue to get a grip of
what is happening locally and i'm
looking forward to that challenge
i mean you forgive me for saying this
coffee but everyone knows that the
government receives money through
general taxation what they're wondering
is when they need help with energy bills
when businesses are going out of
business because they can't afford to
pay their energy they need help from the
government and where is that money going
to come from are you going to borrow it
well i've explained to you that with the
aspects of energy what we're going to do
about that will be set out during this
week
and you people including you will just
have to wait for the detail of that
i will be waiting patiently miss coffee
i do appreciate we are going to find out
eventually i'm sure let's just move on
to the reshuffle uh that we saw
yesterday of course that you got uh the
job of health and social care um but we
did see um
johnny mercer sacked from being veterans
minister and you will have seen i think
perhaps the tweet posted on social media
by his wife covering that
very very upset
describing the person who sacked him at
liz trust as an imbecile
well i'm very conscious that liz has
appointed a really diverse cabinet i'm
delighted that james heapey minister for
the armed forces and now also minister
for veterans will be taking on that role
and will be attending cabinet this
morning
this is i think a government of
of all the talents that we have in this
party and i know that the prime minister
is very focused on delivery uh focused
on pace and that is what we will be uh
aiming to achieve including for our
armed forces and indeed our veterans
i mean but it's not diverse is it when
all the supporters of rishi sunaik have
been sacked and removed from their posts
um i'm very conscious that during the
contest uh the majority of people in
cabinet supported liz trust to become
prime minister liz is now the prime
minister she's appointed i think a
really diverse cabinet
and we will be focused on delivery and
i'm excited about the opportunity to be
part of that
i mean you have no concerns then that
just by appointing allies and supporters
she might well be alienating people
we've seen uh the um the shade being
thrown by johnny mercer's wife we've
seen some other sort of slightly
critical comments by people who've been
removed from jobs and haven't got the
jobs that they wanted
are you confident that the party can
come back together it's just always the
talk throughout the leadership contest
that after the bitterness the party
would have to come back together and
govern
um
liz has appointed a cabinet of a mixture
of whether it's people of her
proactive supporters people who did not
uh support her as well this isn't she
isn't focused on about people who
support her or not she's focused on
about a government of all the talents
the rest of the government will continue
to be appointed during today and i think
that uh people will be able to see that
we will continue to focus and have a
broad church of people in our government
and i'm very conscious that the
conservative party
one of the greatest parties on earth
will continue to be united and to make
sure that we really turn our focus on
delivery of our manifesto delivery
against the challenges that we face
today right now and indeed making sure
that we are also concerned sufficiently
to make sure that we are focused on the
next general election too
so just a convenient coincidence that
all the people that support it are the
most talented ones for the jobs
i'm very conscious that many existing
members of the cabinet
have been reappointed into roles and
privileged to do that and to work
alongside our prime minister
with the plans that we have set forward
and you know obviously we're going to
get all the details in in the coming
days as you say um what we'll have to to
give because there obviously isn't a
magic money tree uh
the country is facing an economic
squeeze so what priorities do you think
of the government will have to give
well as the premises set out during the
campaign her significant focus is about
growing the economy we can't just have a
managed decline that won't help anybody
and that is why in terms of getting
growth going really matters both
uh in terms of making sure that we focus
on making it easier to do business and
that is why i'm really excited by the
appointments that we have uh in the
chancellor in business in trade but this
is a cross-government effort and we will
continue to make sure that we do strain
everything sinew pull every lever that
we can in order to get our economy
growing again
as i say we cannot just look forward to
manage decline and liz has got i think
the bold economic plan to make sure that
we can get on and deliver that
nobody said this is going to be easy
we're conscious that around the world we
have an inflationary challenge
i'm conscious that we will continue to
keep our commitments uh to honor and to
continue to support ukraine as they are
part of this
unnecessary aggressive act of
war by putin on ukraine so there's a
number of challenges of course that this
government is facing today we're not
alone in that in terms of global issues
but we am determined sorry i'm
determined that we will support the
prime minister and we will on the plan
that she's setting out in order to make
sure that we can grow the economy that
we fix the energy challenge and that we
make sure that we uh tackle the backlogs
and also access to primary care
now of course i appreciate of your time
this morning race coffee but just a
couple more questions if you if you will
um
about abortion there have been concerns
raised about your um voting record about
abortion and do you personally support
it
um i'm conscious i have voted against
us abortion laws
what i will say is i'm the complete
democrat and that is done
so it's not that i'm seeking to undo
any um any aspects of abortion laws
yeah i mean just and just to follow up
on that then i mean
women up and down the country people up
and down the country we should be
wanting to know exactly where you stand
on the issue because uh if you're not
entirely supportive of it there will be
some concern and some concerns have been
raised by some support groups for people
who have abortions well what i say is on
the abcd it's about ambulances backlogs
care doctors and dentists
i haven't even considered any other of
those sorts of issues i'm very conscious
that people will have access to the nhs
and
there's nothing more as it were to say
here or we'll see here
okay sorry scotty really good speech
this morning thank you for your time
busy day ahead for you so we'll let you
go thank you thank you
now of course we're going to bring you a
full coverage of liz truss's first pmq's
later on today our political team will
be on hand with their expert analysis
out of her debut against sakirshama that
will be live of course here on sky news
from midday
now still to come on the program uh
strike action continues across a number
of sectors what approach will this trust
take towards the unions i'll be speaking
to mick william from aslav
and boris johnson forced a strong
relationship with the president of
ukraine so later on i'll ask the former
chief of the army if lift trust can
maintain it
now we're going to have plenty of other
big news here from danny few throughout
the morning but first let's take a look
at some of the other stories that are
making headlines this morning now the
mother of nine-year-old olivia pratt
corbell has told her killer to own up in
an emotional video appeal in her first
public remarks since her daughter was
fatally shot in their home in liverpool
cheryl gorbel broke down as she paid
tributes to olivia who she said was her
little shadow ashley hernandez reports
from liverpool
belly two weeks since her daughter was
fatally shot olivia pratt corbell's
mother cheryl remembers her adored
little girl
everyone that she met they all fell in
love with her
she left them all on everyone that she
met
and she may well have only been nine
but she packed a lot in them nine years
her bandaged wrist is a reminder of the
bullet that both injured her and took
her daughter's life speaking to
merseyside police her memories of olivia
reed like the happiest of childhoods
she was amazing
she loved life
she was my little shadow she went
everywhere with me here it is because
she never
never stopped talking
and that's what i miss the most
because i can't hear the talk
it was late evening on the 22nd of
august when a masked gunman forced his
way into her home and there was gunfire
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
olivia here with her father to christmas
market in liverpool was an innocent
victim
he too paid tribute to his nine-year-old
girl
olivia's future has been cruelly
snatched away from her and we have been
deprived of a real light in our lives
olivia's death cannot be in vain and we
want people to feel safe and be safe and
that can only happen if we all come
together and make sure there is no place
for guns or those who use guns on our
streets or in our communities
a plea echoed by olivia's mother the
weapons used that night are yet to be
found
if anyone is hiding these guns
they need to speak up
because they need to be off these
streets
no one no one at all should have to go
through this
those closest to her pleading for
justice for a life cut cruelly short
action horror like sky news in liverpool
now also making news this morning the
president of ukraine vladimir zelinski
has called on the un nuclear watchdog to
force russia into demilitarizing the
zapolice nuclear power plant and return
it to ukraine's control officials from
the iaea travels to the facility last
week and warned there was an urgent need
for interim measures to prevent a
nuclear accident
a report in the washington post says
that details of a foreign government's
military and nuclear capabilities were
among the documents that were seized by
the fbi when they raided donald trump's
florida home last month the paper quotes
people close to the investigation but
doesn't specify which country or whether
the country is hostile to the united
states now sky news has not yet been
able to confirm
the post's reporting
and a woman who can smell parkinson's
has helped scientists at the university
of manchester come up with a test which
sports the disease joy milne from perth
has a rare condition which gives her a
heightened sense of smell the 72 year
old noticed her late husband les
developed a different odour some 12
years before he was diagnosed with
disease as well
and the us e-cigarette maker jewel has
agreed to pay almost 440 million dollars
to settle a multi-state investigation
into its products jewel is accused of
being behind a surge in teenage vaping
by marketing its high nicotine products
to young people the settlement amounts
to a quarter of the company's annual
sales in the u.s
authorities in pakistan are attempting
to widen a breach in its biggest lake to
keep the water there from overflowing
and inundating a 4 500 year old
archaeological site it comes following
an unprecedented monsoon season which
has affected 33 million people that's a
third of the country and left at least 1
325 people dead
all right let's take a look at what the
weather has in store for the next couple
of days here
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now low pressure nearby is keeping
things unsettled with strong winds at
times spells of heavy rain and a risk of
thunderstorms it's a muggy start with
plenty of rain around but much of
central britain is going to be fine any
early fog is now lifting but looks to be
more stubborn across northeast scotland
showers will develop widely through the
morning some heavy and thundery but
there will be sunny spells too meanwhile
more general rain will clear across the
farm of scotland where it'll stay quite
murky
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well in the last hour we spoke to the
new deputy prime minister today's coffee
who told us that liz trust has been
working on plans to provide people with
support to deal with huge energy bills
miss coffee confirms that liz trusts
will set out her plans to parliament and
the country at some time this week
clearly we've just been through a
significant leadership campaign but i
know liz being the serious person that
she is and recognising that we need to
hit the ground running we have been
working on plans as uh potential uh what
we could do uh recognizing that uh in
less than 24 hours uh we've still
certainly working to make sure we
finalize the details of plans on each of
the points uh that we've set out and i
know that this week as the prime
minister
said yesterday uh there will be a
further announcement uh and i'm sure
that that will assure people uh indeed
when they hear what is going to be
offered what we want to do is to grow
the economy and at the moment we have a
high tax burden
we are making sure that we want to focus
on that by mixture of both uh
kind of encouraging investment rather
than putting up corporation tax uh but
also
making sure that we on our manifesto
commitment to the people that voted for
our party in 2019 and that's why we'll
be reversing the national insurance levy
but indeed we just need to continue to
focus on the supply side reform so
making it easier to do business making
it easier to run government
now a cost of living crisis double digit
inflation and a summer of strikes it's
hard to imagine a more economic trickily
economically tricky picture for liz
trust as she takes office now one of her
top priorities is to get britain working
again leaving many wondering that this
means a more hardline approach to
industrial action
well let's bring in the uh general
secretary of the azlev union that is of
course mick wheeler mcqueen good to have
you with us this morning and good
morning to you so there's more strike
action planned how are discussions going
with the companies involved to try and
avert the action
um well we're meeting again today
um at this moment in time we've got
nothing to report i think there's a
difficulty within the constraints that
have been put upon the companies um we
don't actually work for the dft or the
government we actually work for 14
private companies that are making money
that did make money during the pandemic
but we haven't had to pay rise for three
years they've rather morally corruptly
signed a deal with the governments
saying they won't give us more than two
percent during a cost of living crisis
that won't be enough
and it is difficult to find a global
solution
and how concerned are you that with the
new government coming in there may be
more action to try and stop strike
action like yours and and of course try
and stop any coordinated strike hatch in
the maybe plans
well i just heard the uh new health
minister talk about she was a democrat
so we already have the worst trade union
laws in the world
if not europe we have the lobbying
transparency bill with the trade union
bill we already had maggie thatcher's
laws um we're not really the democracy
we pretend to be are we if the voice of
ordinary people when they haven't had a
pay rise for three years or got a
genuine issue with either their employer
or the government can't articulate it
so are you going to go for coordinated
strike action i mean that is going to be
discussed at the trades union congress
in a short while isn't it
i believe workers have got a right to
stand together i've always believed that
you know we should be able to support
the nhs we should be able to support
those in the public sector um and as
part of that debate i do believe that
debate does take place at the tuc we
would support that
yeah so you would be fully in favor of a
general strike that was how it came out
from the discussion to the tec
i believe there's nothing on the floor
or on the table about general strikes
about coordination i believe at this
time moment in time
and um
it's a bit euphemistic isn't it because
if you all go out at the same time it's
essentially going to be a general stroke
okay there's no proposal for a general
strike i mean what how the coordination
might work in my work across sectors
might work in a different way depends
where the debate goes
okay so if the debate went for everyone
to go out on the same day would you be
in favor of that
yes if it actually brings
the government and the employers to
listen to us i've listened to about
managed decline in your previous
interview we've had
managed to climb for 12 years outside
the pandemic we've had the highest
borrowing government we've seen wages
reduced on average by 27.5 percent we've
had the lowest gdp
um quite clearly many of the problems
that we have at the moment are from the
dogma of privatization and that's why we
had the high energy bills we only get
four percent of our energy from russia
other companies made a political choice
to limit those bills so france is four
percent
uh in other countries across europe it's
about seventy percent the increase we're
going to come here to 15
and going higher so all these are
political decisions and invite the
people of the country to turn around to
challenge those decisions in either a
vocal or by demonstrating their concerns
is the right thing to do
yeah i mean the government said there's
a package of measures coming so we'll
wait to hear what is in that and but
you'll know there's been a reshuffle
grand chaps is out from transport as you
said you don't deal directly with those
organ with the government but emery
trevelyan is now imposter how hopefully
are you that that she will be more
receptive to the concerns of workers in
the in the transport sector
well i think we're key to rebuilding the
economy and you know among politicians
all parties talk about a green recovery
from that green new deal i failed to see
without being transported at the center
of that island of this size the
electrification decarbonisation and the
investment from the construction and the
growth that would come from enterprise
and apprenticeships how unless you look
at what you're actually going to grow
and get out of this cycle of cutting the
sector the government is the greatest
engine for procurement the greatest
engine for growth so the opportunity
across the board particularly in
transport and also building all the
millions of houses that we need should
be the things that we should be looking
at to kickstart our economy
yeah and finally then mcqueen i mean how
much you you want this pay rise it's
been resisted of course by the companies
i mean how much do people within the
union discuss the fact that perhaps you
know the quality
and the quality of living may actually
be
on the
plateau it may not be going up
consistently as you would want it to be
well i think you know all of those key
workers including those within the
transport sector um accepted that the
period of time pandemic we weren't going
to pay rise not looking for the pay rise
we haven't had for the last three years
what are we actually looking at a moment
for is a pay rise that reflects um
this year and the cost of living crisis
now quite simply
we work in the industry for employers
that are making money
paying dividends to to their
shareholders so it's not an area whereby
uh our employers aren't making money
surely we should share in the money
that's been made not being isolated from
it and go into to use the words recently
managed to climb
okay mick william from the azlev union
do you appreciate your time this morning
thanks for being with us
thank you
now when liz trust became prime minister
her first phone call with a foreign
leader was with the president of ukraine
and vladimir zelinski now it was a
strong signal of her intention to
maintain support but this could become
more difficult if the war drags on as it
looks like it will with russia making
economic conditions because of its
freezing of fossil fuel supply worse and
joining me from norfolk is the former
chief of the general staff that's
general lord sir richard nana uh lord
danic good to have you with us and thank
you very much um for your time this
morning so from what you've heard from
this trust she wants to increase defense
spending you're confident that the
support for the armed forces and perhaps
support ukraine will continue with this
new administration
well um good morning um
i think there are many things that liz
trust has got to say and do as far as
ukraine is concerned and i think he's
already begun by doing the right things
and that is by having a phone
conversation almost immediately with
president zielinski and presumably
accepting his invitation to go and visit
because it's really really critical that
a country like the united kingdom
continues to give steadfast support to
to ukraine
because i think we've got to see uh the
whole business in ukraine now in the
widest possible concept context uh yes
the supposed counter-offensive around
kirsten is important
possibly in the medium term quite a
defining a series of events in in that
region of southern of southern ukraine
but i think we have to see this thing in
the widest context and that is the
economic war context that vladimir putin
is trying to move the war into and
that's why it is so critical that liz
trust support pledges britain's support
but increasingly also works with her
foreign secretary to make sure that
other european and western allies
also continue to give that steadfast
support and absolutely critically that
the united states does and therefore
again it was good that she talked to
president joe biden yesterday because
without that support uh to ukraine from
the west uh ukraine's fortunes will be
much diminished and it is the wider
context of the economic war that is is
so important that's where vladimir putin
is trying to put pressure on other
western countries not to last the course
because they can't afford it so what
she's doing on the economic front in
this country as we understand is
important that our allies have got to do
the same
yeah and it's the economic war isn't it
that's most important well done it
because obviously that cash is going to
be finite do you see a point
where that money will run out and where
the
the feeling that we should support may
well wayne
well he can't it mustn't for the
security of the west let alone the
security of ukraine that support must be
steadfast and continue and it has to be
expended extended even where further
spending is required into a additional
spending on the united kingdom's armed
forces um her pledge during the election
campaign to move to three percent of gdp
uh being spent on defense by the end of
the decade is really welcome and is
really important and it does mean there
should be a re-evaluation of the
integrated review which was published in
march last year and a re-evaluation of
whether the tilts to the indo-pacific
was indeed right
and of course we have to ask those
questions when we're faced with an ugly
a disastrous land war in europe and that
does lead you to the deduction and of
course you would say i would say this
being a former head of the army that we
need to increase our spending on our
land forces that aspect of our defence
capability
because if we are going to support our
allies the new nato nations of sweden
and finland existing members with a
frontier uh bordering russia like the
baltic states and poland then we need to
be able to make forward deterrent
deployments of our land forces to
support those countries and send a clear
message to vladimir putin you may have
made a disastrous incursion into ukraine
but you must never consider doing it
again into any other country the board
is yours and it's only if we make
forward deterrent deployments like that
with hard capability that we'll be able
to get the message over to him and that
will cost just as the energy price cap
support is going to cost a lot of money
so
less money but still a lot of money an
increase in our defense spending
absolutely has to be made over the next
few years
yeah but look down let me push on again
and i know you're not an economist and a
lot of politicians so this is outside of
europe but that has to be paid for
doesn't it it has to be paid for and
something here perhaps in in social care
in healthcare in education may have to
give to to fund the military like that
are you happy for that kind of balance
to be done
well you say i'm not a politician and
i'm not an economist um we can argue
that one a little bit if you like but
the first duty of government yes is to
defend the security
of the united kingdom itself and its uh
and its inhabitants but also the way the
government does that is by exercising
priorities and choices and there are
some things that are immediately facing
us at the present moment and they are
related to our security and therefore
the increase in borrowing to
deal with the economic issues the energy
crisis that facing us is very very
important as is the increase in defence
spending now
um how are we going to pay for all this
well of course government could reduce
public expenditure in other ways i don't
think that is necessarily even
practically the way to go at the present
moment so we are into in the short to
medium term following borrowing more
although interest rates across the world
have gone up they're still relatively
low in historic terms and therefore the
cost of additional borrowing is
something that this country certainly
for a while can afford to
can expect to afford so it is a question
i'm afraid of going out to the world
markets borrowing further to do those
things that we need to do to defeat
vladimir putin on the economic front and
then to make sure that our deterrent
posture through increased defense
spending particularly on our land forces
is increased to make sure that he is
deterred from any further aggression in
the future
let me talk to you about what's
happening in ukraine and the calls for
this uh demilitarized zone around
zapolicia of course it's held by the
russians right now there are some iaea
uh inspectors monitors on site right now
i mean how would a demilitarized zone
even work in this hot conflict do you
think and is it possible
well the only way it can work is if
there is agreement between russia and
ukraine that such a zone should be put
in place uh it cannot be imposed
externally that would effectively amount
to an armed intervention and actually
armed conflict around zaparica is the
last thing we really want to see but
just as in the same way that turkey was
able to negotiate the grain deal i think
it is quite possible through a third
party and it may well be turkey again an
arrangement could be reached around
zaparica that
a neutral force of some
shape or form
could be invited in to
put a demilitarized zone around zaparica
because i think any rational person
would realize that if there's continued
armed conflict shelling
and the like in and around and on and
into that big nuclear facility the
potential for a disaster of near
chernobyl or fukuyama
consequence of the dimensions is
eminently possible and that he's not in
anybody's interest it's not in the
russians interest it's certainly not in
ukrainian's interest and actually it's
not in the interest more widely so i
think every effort has to be made to
come up with some deal and to
demilitarize the area around zaparica
and if it means asking a third party or
third parties to come in and police that
these all these options should be looked
at none are easy some may dismiss
themselves as being too difficult but
every effort should be made to support
the international atomic authorities to
make sure that we do everything possible
to avoid a nuclear disaster and if one
should happen make sure everything
possible has been done to mitigate the
effects of it in the interests of
millions of people uh in that part of
the world and perhaps more widely
okay general lord richard dan always
great to get your expertise uh thanks
for your time this morning thank
thank
you
all right we're gonna have another chat
with our political correspondent
tomorrow in just a few months but i want
to bring you this footage that's just
coming to us here at sky news it's the
new foreign secretary james cleverley
being asked a question as he makes his
way to westminster take a listen to what
mr cleveland had to say just appointed
to the post yesterday evening
congratulations on the new job
ready to get to work
ready to get to work i do hope he is uh
let's bring in our political
correspondence tomorrow so james
cleveland not saying anything there on
his way here for cabinets and uh the
question was is he ready to get to work
and there was a lot of work for this new
cabinet to get to that's right and just
to give you a sense of what's going on
behind us and the reshuffle is
continuing already we've just seen um ed
argher who is a minister heading into
number 10. he is one of the people who
did resign um to try and bring down
boris johnson as a he was a health
minister he's now back the cabinet
office minister sort of person i was i
would expect to be confirmed by liz
trust in that job everyone who makes
their way up the street into number 10
is getting a job people who get sacked
have it in private over in the commons
but um he's gone in and i think we're
going to continue to see the the
minister minister of state which is
basically the second level down from the
cabinet continue to be appointed this
morning so we'll see whether any sunac
supporters make their way into those
ministerial ranks at all because while
some of them are pretty dismayed that
the cabinet is full of what they see as
liz trust loyalists some are hopeful
that perhaps in the second tier down
which is still very important um they
will have something of a chance to come
back but new cabinet meeting at 8 30
will they be told the details and sign
off on the energy bill package that's
the question for today we won't hear the
details until tomorrow and quasi
quartering the chancellor i've just been
told is meeting with ceos of banks at
the moment to try and soften them up for
what's coming